PROFESSOR: One of the most
important applications
of conditional probability
is in analyzing
the results of diagnostic
tests of uncertain reliability.
So let's look at a
fundamental example.
Suppose that I have a diagnostic
test for tuberculosis.
It really sounds
great because it's
going to be 99% accurate--
in fact, more than 99%
accurate, really,
because here are
the properties this test has.
If you have TB, this test
is guaranteed to detect it
and say, yes, you have TB.
If you don't have
TB, 99% of the time,
the test says correctly
that you don't
have TB, and 1% of the
time, it gets it wrong.
Now, suppose the doctor gives
you the test and the test
comes up saying
that you have TB.
That's kind of scary
because TB is, in fact,
quite a serious disease.
It's getting worse
because there are
all of these
antibiotic-resistant versions
of TB.
Now in Asia, where all the
known antibiotics are not
very effective-- if effective
at all-- of curing it,
and this test that
was 99% accurate
says I have this disease,
it sounds really worrisome.
But in fact, we can
ask more technically,
should you really be worried?
What is the probability given
that this apparently highly
accurate test says you have TB?
What's the probability
that you actually have TB?
That's what we
want to calculate.
What's the probability
that you have it?
So in other words, I want
the conditional probability
that I have TB given that
the test comes in positive.
The test says, yes, you have TB.
That test positive is a big
word that I won't have room
for on other slides,
so let's just
abbreviate it by
[? plus. ?] Plus means,
in green, that the test said,
yes, positive-- you have TB.
OK, so that's the
probability that we're
trying to calculate, this
conditional probability.
What do we know about the test?
Let's translate
the information we
have about the test
into the language
of conditional probability.
And the first thing we said
was that the test is guaranteed
to get it right if you have TB.
So given that you have
TB, the probability
that the test will say so-- it
will return a positive result--
is 1.
Given that you don't
have TB, the probability
that the test will say that you
do have TB is only 1 in 100.
Because 99% of the
time, it correctly
says you don't have TB.
And 1% of the time, it
says oops, you do have TB.
So this is what's called
a false positive rate.
It's falsely claiming that you
have TB when you really don't.
And that rate, we're
hypothesizing, is only 1%.
Now, what we're
trying to calculate,
again, is the probability
that you have TB
given that the test came in
positive and said you had TB.
Well, let's look
at the definition
of conditional probability.
The probability that you have
TB given that the test came
in positive, that said you
do, is simply the probability
that both the test
comes in positive
and you have TB divided
by the probability
that the test comes in positive.
Well, using the definition of
conditional probability again,
this intersection, this AND
of having TB and the test
coming in positive, is
simply the probability
that the test comes
in positive given
that you have TB times the
probability that you have TB.
Now, this one we know.
It's 1 because the
test is perfect.
If you have TB, the
test is definitely
going to say positive.
So that lets me
simplify things nicely.
What I've just figured
out is the probability
that you have TB given
that the test says
you do is simply the
quotient of the probability
that you have TB given no other
information and the probability
that the test comes in positive.
Well, what is that
probability that the test
comes in positive?
How are we going
to calculate that?
That's the key unknown here.
And we're going to use
the probability rule,
the total probability rule.
Total probability says that
you do or you don't have TB.
So that the way to calculate the
probability that the test comes
in positive is to look
at the probability
that the test comes in positive
when you do and don't have TB.
And we know those numbers.
So let's look at the
total probability formula.
The probability that the
test comes in positive
is simply the probability
that it comes in positive
if you have TB times the
probability you have TB,
plus the probability
it comes in positive
given that you don't have TB
times the probability you don't
have TB.
Well, we know a
lot of these terms.
Let's work them out.
Well, the probability the
test comes in positive
given that you have TB is 1.
And the probability
that the test
comes in positive given that
you don't have TB is 1/100.
That's the false positive rate.
We figured that already.
What about the probability
that you don't have TB?
Well, that's simply 1
minus the probability
that you do have TB.
Now I have this nice
arithmetic formula
in the probability of TB.
So I wind up with
the probability
of TB plus 1/100
minus [? 1/100 ?]
of the probability of TB.
It leaves me with 1/100
plus the 99/100 of TB.
So that's what
this simplifies to.
The probability
that the test comes
in positive given
no other information
is 99/100 of the
probability that a person
has TB plus 1/100.
We'll come back to this formula.
Well, we were working
on the probability
that you have TB given
the test came in positive.
We figured out that
it was this quotient.
And now, I know what
the denominator is.
The denominator is 99/100
times the probability
of TB plus 1/100.
Multiply numerator and
denominator through by 100,
and you get that the
probability that you have TB
given that the test says you
do is 100 times the probability
that you have TB divided by 99
times the probability that you
have TB plus 1.
So let's hold formula.
Notice the key unknown
here is the probability
that you have TB independent
of the test, the probability
that a random person in
the population has TB.
If we can figure that out
or if we can look that up,
then we know what
this unknown is,
the probability have TB given
that the test says you do.
Well, what is the probability
that a random person has TB?
Well, there were 11,000 cases of
TB reported in 2011, according
to the Center for Disease
Control in the United States.
And you can assume
that there's going
to be a lot of unreported
cases if there are 11,000
reported ones, because
a lot of people
don't even know they
have the disease.
So let's estimate, on that
basis given that the population
of the US is around 350 million,
that the probability of TB is
about 1/10,000.
Let's plug that
into our formula.
The probability that you have
TB given the test is positive
is this formula.
When I plug in 1/10,000 for TB.
I get 100/10,000 and
99/10,000 plus 1.
Well now, I can see that the
denominator is essentially 1.
It's 1.01.
And the numerator is 1/100.
And this is basically
about 1/100.
In other words, it's not
very likely that you have TB.
Because of the relatively
high false positive rate
that was relatively high of
1%, that false positive rate
washed out the actual number of
TB cases, which the TB rate was
only 0.01%, so that almost
all of the reports of TB
were caused by the high
false positive rate.
And that means that when you
have a report that you've
got TB, you still only have
a 1% chance that you actually
have the TB.
So the 99% accurate
test was not very useful
here for you to figure out
what kind of action to take
and what kind of
medicine to take
or treatment to take given
that the test came in positive.
With 1 in 100
chance, the odds are
you won't do anything,
in which case
you can wonder why your
doctor gave you the test.
Well, the 99% test sounds good.
We figured out that it isn't.
And a hint about why 99%
accurate isn't really so useful
is that there's an obvious
test that's 99.99% accurate.
What's the test?
Always say no.
After all, the probability
is only 1 in 10,000
that you're going to be wrong.
And that's the 99.99% rate.
So it sounds as though this
test is really worthless.
But no, it's not.
If you think about it a
little bit, it will be useful.
And I'll explain
that in a minute.
I forgot I'm getting
ahead of myself.
Because the basic formula
that we used here was we
figured out what the
probability of TB
given that the test
said you had TB in terms
of the inverse probabilities
which we knew-- that is,
the probability that the
test came in positive given
that you had TB.
This is an example of what's
a famous rule in probability
theory.
It's called Bayes'
rule, or Bayes' law.
And this is it.
It's just stated in terms
of arbitrary events A and B.
It expresses the
probability of B
given A in terms of the
probability of A given
B and the probabilities
of A and B independently.
Now, I can actually
never remember this law,
but I re-derive it
right every time
I need to do it as we've
done in the previous slides.
It's really a quite
straightforward law
to derive and prove.
But let's go back to this
99% accurate test that
seemed worthless since there
was a trivial test that
was 99.9% accurate.
But in fact, it's really
helpful because it
did increase the
probability that you
had TB by a factor of 100.
Before you took the test and
before you know anything,
you thought that
your probability was
the same as everybody
elses-- about 1 in 10,000.
Now the test says
the probability
that you have TB is 1 in 100.
That's a hundred times larger.
What's the value of that?
Well, suppose you only had
5 million doses of medicine
to treat this American
population of 350
million people.
Who should you medicate?
Well, if you medicated a
random 5 million people
out of 350 million,
the likelihood
that you're going to get very
many of the real TB cases
is small.
It's only going to
be about 1 in 30.
You'll only get about
1/30 of the cases.
But if you use your
5 million doses
to medicate the 3.5 million
people who would test positive
under this 99%
accurate test, then
when you test all
350 million people,
you're going to get about 3.5
million who test positive.
You have enough medication
to treat all of them.
And if you treat
all of them, you're
almost certain to get all of
the actual TB cases, all 10,000
of them.
So the 99% accurate test
does have an important use
in this final
setting, a lot more
so then the 99.99% accurate
test that simply always said
no-- food for thought.